une visite placée sous le signe des
manifestations le déplacement du
président français dix ans notamment à
appuyer les volontés de réforme du pays
voit son séjour à nouveau marquée par
les témoignages d'exaspération des
libanais nous disons à macron que nous
sommes contre le premier ministre
désigné et nous savons que matheron a
choisi ce nom est cette chose est
inacceptable le pouvoir qui nous a
gouverné affamés et rendu pauvres est le
même qui nous a tués
et ce pouvoir et les représentants
actuels de l'autorité sont tous
responsables du crédit qui correspond au
meurtre délibéré d'un grand nombre de
libanais en cause la désignation récente
du nouveau premier ministre moustapha
adib qui souffrent d'avoir été choisis
comme ses prédécesseurs par les forces
politiques traditionnelles jeune homme
l'ambassadeur mustapha adil pour former
le nouveau gouvernement
comme nous l'avons annoncé hier après la
réunion des anciens premiers ministres
notre objectif doit être la
reconstruction de beyrouth en
particulier après l'explosion et de
mettre en oeuvre les réformes
financières et économiques que nous
connaissons tous
dès son arrivée à l'aéroport de beyrouth
emmanuel macron a été clair il n'est pas
au liban pour adouber ou non le nouveau
premier ministre
mais pour appuyer la mise en place d'un
gouvernement de mission objectif mettre
en oeuvre des réformes susceptibles de
satisfaire les libanais ma position est
toujours la même c'est celle de
l'exigence sans ingérence j'ai vu qu'un
processus s'était enclenchée ces
dernières heures qui a permis de faire
émerger une figure en tant que premier
ministre il ne m'appartient aucunement
ni de l'approuver de l'adouber 7 la
souveraineté libanaise qui est ici en
jeu mais de m'assurer que c'est bien un
gouvernement de mission qui sera formé
au plus vite pour mettre en oeuvre les
réformes que nous connaissons au service
des libanaises et des libanais réforme
des marchés publics de lutte contre la
corruption pour la justice pour la
réforme de l'énergie de l'électricité
pour une meilleure gestion du port pour
une aussi meilleure gestion de la banque
centrale et du système bancaire des
discussions avec les principaux
responsables politiques ont lieu mardi
après midi au palais présidentiel de
baabda entouré entre autres de son
homologue michel aoun et du nouveau
premier ministre moustapha adib le chef
de l'état on a profité pour prévenir les
dirigeants libanais qu'il s'exposait à
des sanctions s'il ne parvenait pas à
tracer dans les trois mois un nouveau
cap
six rendez-vous de fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons en tirer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien n'a été fait et ce moment là
c'est clair je devrais dire à la
communauté internationale
nous ne pouvons pas être au rendez-vous
de l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanaises
et aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
ce que je l'aurais instamment demandé ce
sur quoi toutes les formations
politiques sans exception se sont
engagés ce soir ici même c'est que la
formation de ce gouvernement ne
prendrait pas plus de quinze jours
tout n'est donc pas réglé à la fin de
son second séjour
mais face à la colère grandit
santes du peuple libanais emmanuel
macron semble décidée à maintenir la
pression sur le gouvernement
un troisième voyage au liban est prévue
en décembre prochain